what's up guys my name is Samuel EADS
and in this video I'm going to be
answering your property investment
questions from last week now there's
absolutely loads of questions and
they're really good questions so I'm
just gonna rattle through I'm an answer
as many as I can
concise and quick and to the point
that's my plan
here's the thing though if you've got a
property investment question something
that's bugging you comment below because
next week I've been doing another video
just like this and I'll be answering the
comments to this video so get commenting
below also while I'm talking and while
I'm answering questions from last week
if you have a question that pops up then
comment it below so watch the video
enjoy comment and don't forget as well
to smash the like button subscribe
further notification bell on because if
you comment below and ask a question and
next week I answer your question which I
probably will do you're not going to
even know because you're not going to
get our notifications to subscribe to
turn the notification bell on and let's
get started so what we got ignorant of
the law is no excuse hi Samuel how can
you recognize that a property is in
negative equity if you want to buy a
property that's in negative equity
specifically because you want to take it
over on a lease option agreement or
negotiate something creative like that
which is a memory down deal what I do is
I go to areas that have bottomed out
places like Liverpool Hall Bradford to
be honest is that even places even more
central to the Midlands like
stoke-on-trent and what I do is I look
at how much are they asking for what's
the sale price and then I look at how
much did they pay for it and if they
bought it for really high and now
they're selling it for really low and
you can find this information online for
free it's really simple you can go on
Rightmove and you can click on market
info for example but there's lots of
ways if they bought it for a hundred
grand and now they're selling it for 60
grand
guess what they've bought it for a
hundred probably with a mortgage they're
selling it for 60 grand and they can't
sell it for 60 grand and no one's buying
it but they can't drop the price because
the mortgage is 60 grand they're in
negative equity that's when I'll come on
I'm gonna say I'll buy off you for 70
grand you can't sell it to 60 but I'll
buy in seven years time which will give
the market chance to recover in the
meantime I'll take over the mortgage
payments or become the landlord and if
they're motivated enough to sell and
they're in negative equity suddenly I
haven't taken control of that property
I'm paying them all
but I'm ready now renting out so I'm
getting paid and I don't own it and in
seven years I have the option not the
obligation to buy it for 70,000 pounds
and we know that when things have
bottomed out
we know it's only going to go back up
they bought it for a hundred thousand
pound back in the day it's going to go
back up so that's how I recognized our
properties the negative equity that's
kind of my strategy this is something as
well that we do on the property
investors crash course I will leave a
link in the description below if you
want to come to the crash course we
actually do this live at the property
investors crash course you'll literally
be picking up the phone doing deals over
the two days and I'll leave a link below
and it's on the house as well okay so
below alright what else we got Connor
Baker there's five Samuel thanks for the
content look forward to seeing you on
the crash course in February boom Shaka
can you beat RR on a tracker mortgage
rather than a bridge okay comment what
you want to do when you do buy with
service refinance generally speaking
what we do is we bridge initially so we
will all just use cash because the thing
is if you get a mortgage on a property
like even if it's a track of mung beans
if you get a mortgage it's going to be
less attractive for the seller to give
you a good price if you say I'm buying
it cash baby I'm a cash buyer when you
become a cash buyer certainly what
happens is you get things cheaper so you
buy it for cash or you use your own cash
or abridging loan then you lift the
value you've got to find a way of
pushing the value up but it might just
be a case of making it more visible and
then you're going to refinance I
normally just refinance on the
fixed-rate normal buy to let mortgage
dependent on the property so that's
generally the strategy that we do we'll
go over this at the crash course I'll
see you there in February hopefully as
well man so get yourself there and heard
the helps okay what else we've got Josh
canna for says I'm Samuel I've been
following you for a good while now
awesome thank you for following me for a
good while and I've been looking at the
went to service accommodation strategy
but I just found out that the area of
interest is becoming restricted how
would you approach the situation with a
lot of time invested already into the
strategy in that location Josh you've
invested a lot of time into this area
and you've been doing it and you've been
excited and you've been doing
spreadsheets and you
due diligence and you've been dreaming
about it and now you found out that the
area is restricted I don't know what
that means exactly and what in what
capacity but probably it means it's no
good and now you're emotionally invested
in the area and you're like what can I
do because I know I know this because
you say I've already invested a lot of
time into this location but the thing is
you just kind of move location now and
you've got to use all of that due
diligence that you did the tech you know
the template that you've created by
doing the due diligence you can now just
do that in another area just not
restrict it as disappointing as that
answer might be
you need to discipline your
disappointment move to another area
because the worst thing people can do is
buy because they're emotionally invested
in an area or they're emotionally
invested in a house you don't want to be
a motivated buyer oh I know it's a
Breton service accommodation but if
you're like motivators has to work and
you try and force a deal sometimes no
deal is better than a bad deal so it
depends on how restricted I don't know
what you mean by like the area's
restricted maybe let me know in the
comments on this video but I would just
say move area just find another area
where you like yes this works it might
be that the same thing happens again you
might move to another area you might
spend you know three or four solid days
doing all you do diligence and get an
excited and then suddenly ah you find
out that there's some issue it's
oversaturated or there's a rule there
and you're gonna have to do another area
and it takes time I mean this is why I
want training programs to save people
the pain of exactly that so if you've
not done any of that training program do
it don't invest in an area is bad just
because you felt like you've invested
the time into it alright next Thomas
calves D says Samuel is it possible to
convert a house to a small HMO for four
people only in article 4 unfortunately
my friend is not article 4 when article
4 comes into an area you can't even do 3
bedrooms you just cannot rent out a
house smoking about by the room you just
can't do it because you've got to get
planning permission actually go for is a
[ __ ]
and obstacle force coming all over the
country I used to say to people don't
worry about article 4 because there's
only a very small few areas now it's
like probably a third of the country's
article 4 and on to before is coming
into more and more areas and in five
years time people are gonna say to me
Samuel do remember in 2021 you could
just buy a house and rent the room
with no planning no even licensed if it
was less than five people like those
were the days weren't they ever move
those were the days those are the days
because if you buy a house and you rent
it out by the room and then they bring
in article for
you don't need planning because you got
in early you'd only planning you have
the grandfather rights you have
automatic planning permission just get
in early you know get in early find an
area that's not article four yet where
it's coming the council have to give you
twelve months notice before they bring
in r2 before get into an area where
they're bringing in r2 before like where
it's gonna be the next question last
year I bought a property turned into a
Joan Doncaster I completed on the
property and then in July rented the
rooms out October 2019 article four came
in I'm all good this year 2020 in June
they're bringing out two before all
throughout Birmingham so Birmingham is
going to be a no-go for buying houses
and turn them into HMOs as from June
2020 guess what I'm doing right now
guess what my students are doing right
now buying houses in Birmingham renting
them out by the room waiting for article
four to come in when article four comes
in the house prices are gonna go up
about a girl per value of course it's
gonna kill the competition off because
no one else can do HMOs we've got
automatic planning permission we've got
grandfather rights and it's gonna push
the rents up because there's no more
competition and there's gonna be so many
people in 2023
those were the days those are the days
that you lose a thing to say these are
the days get in the right area get in
the right strategy get in with the right
people I don't even have to say this on
youtube like for free I'm telling you I
tell I'm telling people I did a video
recently saying this is what I'm buying
this is what I bought last year this is
my business plan this is I I'm telling
you exactly what to do exactly how to do
it a lot of my training is even free on
YouTube and my crash courses and the
reason I do this is because I hold
everything with open hands
I don't think competitively I think
collaboratively and as long as when you
become successful just let me know you
know let me know if you become
financially free drop me a message and
I'll have you on winners Wednesday let's
see what else we got if you enjoyed the
video please do smash the like button if
you not subscribe subscribe Paul
omerta so what are the top three books a
new real estate investor should read
before investing obviously my book of
course buy low rent high or so I've
written a book called financial freedom
in seven days and there's such easy
reads I would also say you've got to
read Rich Dad Poor Dad by Robert
Kiyosaki he talks about debt and how you
can use debt as good debt and passive
income and it's just like a real
game-changer if you've not read that and
you're new to this whole world
well there we go those three books
Barlow and high financial freedom in
seven days both by Samuel Leeds not
biased
maybe a little and Rich Dad Poor Dad
Robert Kiyosaki what else we got Lucy
door I say we just ordered your book
thank you for the info based on view
videos I decided to tell my flat in
London about two properties up north to
rent out cool probably a good decision
as long as you buy right I signed a
two-year fixed term mortgage on my
property there's an early get out fee of
two thousand five hundred and twenty
seven twenty twenty my mortgage company
won't let me take it to a new property
if I swap from residential supply select
which is my plan is there any way out of
it with the fee or should I just wait it
out and put it up for sale in November
thanks so you've got a pay fee of 2,500
which is a penalty fee so you can either
not pay two thousand five hundred and
wait almost a year but then you're going
to think how much money are you losing
in that year if you sold the property in
London or the two properties in London
and you invest it elsewhere smart and
believe me you can invest so smart like
your your houses at the minute I
probably I'm guessing the house isn't
probably I'm giving you a great return
how much money are you losing if you
wait a year and is it a lot more than
two and a half thousand in which case
maybe it's worth just swallowing the fee
and taking it on the chin and paying the
two and a half thousand pounds because
it's your decision I don't know what
properties you've got I don't know what
properties you're looking to buy but
sometimes you just got a look at the
bigger picture rather than dying on the
wrong mountain
okay next right claw I hope I pronounced
that right Ryan I Samuel looking to buy
a house and converting it to a 3-bit HMO
all three rooms will be just above the
double bedroom roof standards my
question is do I charge more for a
double bedroom say 125 a week in the
view that two people can potentially
stay in the room or should I charge what
I think a room or when
90 pound a week you've got to rent out
what the going rate is you know people
said oh that's too expensive it's like
as a business person which is what you
are because you have a product which is
your house and you have a customer which
is your tenant you just go charging
people want to pay so look on spare room
and see what people look wanting to pay
look at your competitors if your people
are wanting to pay speak to some hmm
management companies in the area asked
them what people are wanting to pay and
then charge what people are wanting to
pay if you've got two people in one room
or normally charge extra I'll normally
charge an additional fee because there's
two of them and also our normally I only
do one room in the house if you've got
say five rooms and you've got two - two
- two - that's ten people in the house
it's kind of crazy so normally I'll I'll
charge extra and I'll have one probably
the largest room I'll have a couple in
there you just got a charge what you can
charge man you've got to charge a good
rate where people will move in offer a
good service and let the marketplace
dictate what that price is
Callum Gallagher oMG you answered thank
you so much I finally understand I'm
only 16 but can't wait to come to your
crash course in a few years how old do I
have to bake don't wait a few years get
down to the kruskal's now you're 16
years old I don't know what the rules
are you know every once I really publish
it I get asked this a lot I should
probably actually ask the like the
operations team and everything in the
office what the rules are but we get a
lot of teenagers to come to the crash
course with all people young people all
kind of people in between I think you
might have to be 18 to come alone but if
you're 16 just come down moving out or
just come down with with one of your
parents one of your cousins someone
that's 18 or over get down don't wait a
few years man this is the time don't
wait for years but Callum thanks for
commenting and I appreciate you support
all right spider-man one two three four
five six seven eight nine three said I
Samuel I had attended the crash course
okay I hope you liked it I'm sure you
did
in July last year in Birmingham and I'm
currently saving for the Academy boom
shucks aha good for you man respect when
looking at Br do you make an offer on
the house first and then get the loan or
do you get the loan first also is this a
good strategy for beginners as most
bridging loan companies ask you if you
already own a house my understanding
actually is that is is that with
bridging it's like the easiest kind of
finance that you could possibly want to
get because there
care about you they care actually more
about the investment opportunity
bridging companies so okay first thing I
would do is I would speak to a broker
and I'll just see can you get a mortgage
you know what's what's the crack you
know assuming that you found a good
property so you kind of if that's called
like a decision in principle you know
based on you buying a hundred grand
house yes we could give you finance and
this is what it would look like this is
what we charge you so you've got like an
in-principle offer going on then once
you've got that you're going to go and
view the houses you're going to you're
going to put the offers forward and
you're going to say look this is my mom
with your principal and then if the
offer is accepted unless you're buying
from auction which is probably not smart
in your situation on your first property
and things like that unless your mom
from auction put the offer forward
offers accept it and then say awesome
thank you Dan tell your mortgage broker
that the offer has been accepted then
the mortgage broker will then get the
actually get the finance not in
principle but get it for that particular
investment and if he can't for whatever
reason if the brokers is actually you
know what this we can't we can't do this
then you just have to tell the estate
agent man I'm so sorry I had an incision
in principle but I can't get I can't
icon so you're always gonna offer first
you know you can't get all your ducks
completely in a row before you start
offering so I think did that answer your
question in tow is it a good strategy by
refurbished refinance yeah for sure it's
a great strategy for beginners as long
as you do it right and the fact you've
been to the crash course gives me
confidence that you probably gonna
you're probably on the right track for
sure so good job hoped answered your
question
JR says why would they lend you seventy
five percent of an evaluation when you a
mortgage there's a lot of questions now
okay I'm screening one or two more why
would they lend you seventy five percent
of the new valuation because that's the
new valuation a lender will give you
always they'll give you lend you seventy
five percent of what the value is so if
you own a house for a hundred grand and
there's no mortgage on it and you go to
a lender and say can you lend me money
against this house this house is the
collateral they'll lend you they won't
give you a hundred grand but don't give
you 75 grand typically and buy-to-let
circumstances so if you buy a house for
a hundred grounds and then you push the
value up and now the values 150 grand
guess what they'll give you 75 percent
of 150 grand so they'll always give you
75 percent of the value generally
speaking because the bank the lender
wants a little bit of security so they
know that you've got
bit of skin in the game yourself by the
way that little bit of skin in the game
yourself that 25% that doesn't have to
be your money I thought that can be
someone else's money now we're talking
about really leveraging but that's the
friend of the video
slow-mo ffice okay tell me what are your
thoughts on buying a new build for the
purpose of renting out do new builds
tend to go up in value any faster than
existing or about the same Thanks
I would never owns I never but if
someone built a house brand new I
wouldn't in buy the house because it
seems you buy the house stay gonna drop
in value if you're building the house
depends I mean I build houses but I
probably wouldn't build one house
because the amount effort energy takes
to buy the land or the house you may as
well build five or six right if you buy
a piece of land and then build six
houses on it we did that in Lincoln
we're now doing that we're buying pieces
of land I've just been out looking
around Stoke and Manchester just two
days ago by Beatle and build five or six
houses and that can be really profitable
because then you can either sell the
houses and make profit or you can refine
that to pull your money out and then
rent that can be really profitable but I
probably wouldn't buy an existing new
brothers just being built that's all we
have time for today folks while we've
got there was a lot of good questions I
really you know what what I love about
you guys so I've got now I think 150 to
150 to thousand subscribers on YouTube
or there and there abouts that's quite a
big number of subscribers but the
subscribers that follow me are actually
smart you know they understand Lease
Option agreements rent to rents HMOs buy
refurbish refinance and I can tell that
you guys are smart from your questions
however there's no such thing as a
stupid question so regardless of how
clever of your question is a stupid your
question might sound there's no such
thing as a stupid question when I
started in this game about eleven twelve
years ago I knew absolutely nothing at
all so you know please do comment you
have your questions I'm not gonna judge
your questions I'm just gonna answer
them for those advanced people you know
respects my own respects that you're
really taking your education seriously
for those people that are on the academy
or they'll come down to the crash course
or that boat onto the crash course
respect because I really think they
don't teach this stuff in schools in
school they don't teach money in school
that in teach wealth I don't teach money
management they don't even teach how to
write check they don't teach you about
mortgages that are just your bad debt
nothing in school and then even if you
go and study economics or go and study
business in universe
today like I'm not being funny but
you're probably going to be being taught
by someone that read some books you know
so that's why I really feel passionate
I've built up a successful property
portfolio I'm successful in property
myself I feel really passionate about
actually passing that and giving back
and teaching people we have a training
business and some of the training we do
have advanced training programs there is
an investment for that I don't even take
a salary from the training company you
know I do this genuinely because I just
really enjoy it
so thank you guys for your support I
really appreciate you thank you for the
subscribers if you're not subscribed
subscribe and afford to reading your
comments and if you want to come and
join us at the crash course I'll leave a
link in the description below or you can
just do it right here get yourself
hooked on the cross right here and get
yourself subscribed if you're not
already right here as well subscribe
Bach on the crash course I'll see you
there thanks then would you support